[Musique]
l'automne dernier une adolescente
britannique de 14 ans atteinte d'un
cancer en phase terminale a obtenu de la
haute cour de londres
le droit d'être cryogénisé c'est à dire
d'être congelé après sa mort dans
l'espoir de pouvoir être ressuscité est
guéri un jour certains voient dans la
cryogénisation une technologie
prometteuse
d'autres estiment que ça suscite de faux
espoirs état des lieux avec l'astronaute
julie payette préserver son corps pour
une longue période de temps et se
réveiller plus tard intacte ça fait
partie de la science fiction depuis
longtemps dans les films les voyageurs
s'en donne le temps de faire un vol
intersidéral ou simplement pour se
retrouver dans le futur dans la vraie
vie on est bien loin de cette réalité
si je aujourd'hui il est possible de
faire conserver son corps entier dans la
zone cliquer ou simplement son cerveau
mais on ne peut le faire qu'après la
main et à ce jour aucun être humain
n'est jamais revenu à la vie avec ce
procédé
la pratique reste marginal il y a même
des pays qui l'interdisent
à ce jour environ 350 personnes ont opté
pour la cryogénisation et contrairement
à la légende
walt disney n'est pas de cela il a été
incinéré
mais quand on y pense
l'idée de se préserver pour un avenir
meilleur est loin d'être nouvelle car le
rêve de vivre éternellement
ça ne date pas d'hier
en égypte ancienne par exemple la
momification permettait de conserver le
corps et certains organes en vue d'une
nouvelle vie on modifiait d'ailleurs les
gens avec des possessions et des animaux
de compagnie pour le réveil éventuelle
mais pour que ça fonctionne ça suppose
que l'esprit de la personne va faire le
même voyage à voir les momies
aujourd'hui on peut douter du succès ce
que la cryogénisation propose c'est une
solution scientifique du moins en
apparence mais vendre de l'immortalité
en misant sur les progrès de la science
c'est trompeur parce que le véritable
enjeu c'est d'abord de bien conserver
les corps et la technologie est encore
loin d'être au point
le plus gros défi c'est le lot on le
voit bien avec un fruit en gelant l'eau
prend de l'expansion et le fruit se
déforme et à l'intérieur les cristaux de
glace perse les membranes des cellules
et vous le savez quand on le des jeunes
ça ne ressemble plus tellement
l'original
la solution actuelle c'est de remplacer
l'eau par un liquide qui ne gèle pas une
sorte d'anti gel quoi on parle alors de
vitrification
une technique qui est déjà utilisée dans
les cliniques de fertilité
certains enfants ont été conçus à partir
d'embryons vitrifiés
à très basse température le liquide
antigel se solidifie mais ils
endommagent pas les cellules sauf que ça
fonctionne seulement petit et chez
quelques scènes au maximum
on le corps humain en entier cet
infiniment plus complexe chaque organe
est différent que ce soit dans sa
structure son contenu en eau ses besoins
en oxygène pour vitrifier un corps
complet il faudrait réussir à drainer
tout le liquide pour le remplacer par
l'antigel médical puis le refroidir de
façon uniforme pour éviter l'apparition
de fissures même dans les laboratoires
de pointe
on n'a jamais réussi à vitrifier
séparément un seul organe sans faire de
dommages alors imaginez avec le cerveau
100 milliards de neurones tous
interconnectés
c'est une structure très délicat où sont
conservés nos souvenirs
notre identité nos talents la moindre
dégradation serait catastrophique
malgré tout il resterait bien quelques
cellules utilisable pour vous faire un
clan n'ont peut-être sauf que votre
personnalité ne suivrait pas ont
fabriqué un corps qui vous ressemble
mais vous n'auriez même pas conscience
la réponse des futurologues convaincu
c'est qu'un jour la médecine va trouver
la solution à tous les problèmes
on peut toujours rêver des conflits des
tissus humains et réparer tous les
dégâts
ça serait déjà un travail colossal alors
imaginez redonner la vie est de toute
façon qui va le font avec l argent et
surtout pourquoi
pour l'instant donc il faut voir la
cryogénisation comme un rite funéraire
moderne qui emprunte son vocabulaire à
la science fiction
tant mieux si ça permet de faciliter un
deuil ou de composer avec l'angoissé
c'est un jour d'exister mais d'un point
de vue scientifique il est difficile de
croire que ce qu'on préserve aujourd'hui
avec des techniques inadéquate sera
réparable dans le futur l'immortalité
ce n'est pas pour demain et honnêtement
c'est probablement une bonne chose
et c'est julie payne au psg